[Musique]
ces 12 millions de sacs donc s'agit
selon considéré comme le premier à faire
d'une multitude d'autres à venir
et c'est depuis ce succès ses collègues
d enlever le regarder le suremballage
qui aux yeux juin faire encore mais ça
s'en vient ça va nous obliger à prendre
un sac dans nos autos pas qu'on change
de taux on va parler justement de cette
nouveauté le bannir les sacs de
plastique dans des épiceries iga lance
la balle ça va être vraiment le premier
ça va sur le secteur de montréal par là
dessus ça va être progressivement
ailleurs sobey's dans quelques mois
tous les magasins de cette chaîne le
vent à interdire les sacs en plastique
jusqu'à maintenant on avait le choix si
on n'avait pas nos sacs qu'on se
procurer nous mêmes on pouvait toujours
en acheter à la caisse a dans cette
époque la danse et ses chaînes là ça va
être terminé
on va en parler avec marc-olivier son
expert de ces questions là c'est un
professeur chercheur au centre de
transfert technologique en écologie
industrielle sociale université de
sherbrooke
bonjour monsieur olivier du donjon bon
monsieur olivier alors ils sont les
premiers sont obèses avec grh halle
berry est ce que j'ai une bonne idée
d'être le premier à le faire d'abord
vous savez que c'est le premier à faire
à le faire ici mais on sait pas les
premiers à le faire dans le monde dans
bien d'autres continents sur bien
d'autres continents dans bien d'autres
pays c'est déjà fait on est un peu à la
traîne là pour bouger pour réagir et
fort heureusement on se rend compte que
là on a une entreprise commerciale qui
dit nouveau prendre les devants nous on
va profiter d'un marchandisage va dans
le bon sens du terme on parce que ce
sont des grands groupes parce que ils
ont déjà adopté depuis longtemps des
politiques environnementales
ils ont des équipes qui travaillent
aussi en environnement à l'intérieur de
leur centre administratif et là ils nous
disent bas et c'est le temps de bouger
hiro sens très bien que de toute façon
vous aurez pas le choix puisque on y lit
au revoir de la réglementation qui va
forcer que ce mouvement-là à se faire à
l'échelle des provinces ou à l'échelle
du canada
parce que de toute façon tout le monde
on est en train de le faire il
d'ailleurs nos clients nous le demande
il remarque d'ailleurs on parlait du
géant qui disait qu'à 60% déjà de leurs
consommateurs arrivent avec leurs
propres sacs ici est ce qu'on peut dire
vraiment qu'on est en train de passer à
l'autre étape de la fin des sacs de
plastique
oui je pense qu'on peut le dire ça
annonce quelque chose parce qu'à partir
du moment qu'un grand groupe décide de
le faire
quelques moureaux disons avant que ça
soit obligatoire de le faire vous allez
pouvait être certain que tous les autres
concurrents de ce grand groupe le vent
devoir se positionner ou aussi est ce
qu'ils attendent d'être obligé par une
législation pour le faire ou est-ce
qu'au contraire eux aussi sont capables
de montrer qu'ils ont d'initiative sur
sa préoccupation environnementale que
les consommateurs ont et en plus ils n'y
ont pas que il peut s'appeler assortie
d'autres mesures rires on utilise des
fois l'expression des mesures
compensatoires ou des mesures de
mitigation reste un peu la même chose là
on n'arrive pas simplement en disant
ignorer plus de sacs d'épicerie
on arrive en disant comment on peut
faire pour que les gens se souviennent
d'apporter un sac d'épicerie
voilà vous allez voir arriver des
terrains de stationnement devant les
grandes épiceries en banlieue avec les
zones près des portes qui sont réservées
pour les clients qui apportent leur sac
si vous apportez pas leur sac soit bien
identifiée vous devez aller stationner
plus loin et regardez là c'est pas
vraiment qu'il va y avoir une police qui
va faire la différence c'est qu'on va
renforcer des trucs des façons de faire
en sorte que lis-je se souvient me qui
passe à l'action et en même temps on va
avoir aussi des présentoirs ou avons été
invités à laisser des sacs en surplus
que l'on a poursuivi on oublié dans la
rue et ça parce qu'il va falloir penser
pratico pratique
moi j'aimerais qu'on pense environnement
parce que ça c'est vraiment votre grande
spécialité vous avez un regard très
critique là dessus parfois on se dit bon
bah ça va être simple
on va porter mon type de sac moi je vous
ai apporté tout ce qu'on a retrouvée
juste ici avec les collègues là dans les
types de sacs qui existent encore alors
il ya ce très très léger comme ça que je
déchire dans leurs vingt ans ils ceux
qui sont plus éclairés qu'on peut
acheter quelques cents là à la caisse et
puis il ya ce qu'on achète comme seule
leçon
plus résistant mais on se demande
parfois si la vague britpop par la suite
mais il ya des sacs en tissu si on veut
faire le bon choix aux parfaits je
profite de ce moment là moi je vais
arriver avec mon sac mais je veux rester
dans l'esprit écologique lequel je
prends d'abord tous les sacs les deux
premiers qui sont des sacs très mauvaise
il ce sont des sacs qui sont tellement
minces que dès qu'on va emporter des
shows de danse à vous commencez à
s'étirer soit commencé à se déchirer
banque sal ils sont déjà bannis dans la
marge brute mais la majorité dans un
très grand nombre de villes ils sont
déjà bannis on ne peut plus s'en sert
des succès profite justement de ce sac
donc les sacs de plastique qui ont 50
millièmes et plus sont présentement
autorisé alors qu'est ce qui va arriver
de cscec est-ce qu'on va les bannir
complètement c'est ce qu'on a compris on
a compris que on sera encore plus
restrictif sur les sacs
moi je vais vous donner un exemple bien
particulier dans mon quartier la
meilleure boulangerie de tous les
quartiers soit je suis certain c'est la
meilleure eh ben la boulangère qui est
là elle est passée des sacs très minds à
des sacs plus épais et puis l'ol a
réalisé le même plutôt que de payer
d'offrir des sacs plus épais elle
pouvait tout simplement demandé à ses
clients d'avoir un sac permanent d'avoir
un sac comme nos sacs d'épicerie
si bien qu elle nous incite dorénavant
depuis desjardins boutarel pas attendu
qu'à une législation
elle nous incite à apporter un sac et un
cercle pour le réemploi nature et si on
continue ses sacs la leçon on les achète
aussi dans les épiceries est-ce que
c'est écologique c'est ça que c'est
écologique si vous en servez il veut
conserver plusieurs fois alors quand on
parle de l'empreinte environnementale
de telle ou telle matière d'un sac 9 qui
fait en coton ou d'insectes qui est fait
d'un plastique résistant l'empreinte
environnementale ça va avec quoi ça va
avec finalement l'idée qu'on peut se
servir de cet objet là un grand nombre
de fois ci je me sers 32 fois de ce sac
là je divise par 32 l'empreinte
environnementale qui est strictement lié
à ceux à produire ce sac là et c'est ça
qui est l'idée derrière il faut qu'on
cesse d'utiliser les plastiques à usage
unique
ce qu'on utilise quelques minutes et que
l'on jette ses soldats bord qui doit 10
par ailleurs elle sonnerait pas passer
directement aux sacs en tissu on
pourrait mais dans les sacs en tissu cio
de tout aussi tout comme dans ses sacs
plus permanent de tous alors il ya des
sacs qui sont produits avec beaucoup
d'efforts qui sont imprimés qui ont des
graphismes qui font modernes qui font
qu'ils annoncent quelque chose de votre
personnalité
oui est ce que c'est ça que vous l'avoir
ou est-ce que vous la voir un sac et un
sac et curieux qu'il n'ya pas
d'impression donc oubliez pas qu à
chaque fois que vous faites un
traitement supplémentaire sur les tissus
pour faire un sac à chaque fois il ya
toujours un petit peu plus dans la
comptabilité de l'empreinte
environnementale
mais que ce soit le sac en tissu ou prou
ce soit le sac en plastique
la seule solution c'est de s'en servir
régulièrement abondamment à répétition
et là à ce moment là on se met dans les
meilleures conditions lors on comprend
fort si on en a on lutte à la corde
oui à la corde et on est d'accord que
les sacs en tissu sont plus faciles à
laver une fois de temps à autre les sacs
qui sont en plastique souvent on voit
lille avait un peu où on veuille lier la
vie comme on dit la débarbouillette
quelque chose comme ça mais chacun
trouve sa façon avec son mode de vie sur
un problème mais on rend dans une autre
étape c'est ce que je retiens aussi
cette entrevue mais c'est olivier merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là bas voilà alors
à tous bon sac